this is an 8 news now breaking news
alert
and we are tracking a developing story
up in the northeast valley tonight after
a woman was found dead in a shooting we
do thank you for joining us i'm brian
loftis and i'm denise valdez as brian
just mentioned this is in the northeast
part of las vegas near lake mead in
hollywood that's where we find 8 news
now reporter madison kimbrell live at
the scene with an update madison
yes to me so all we know as of now is
that one woman is dead we're currently
at the desert ridge apartments off of
lake mead boulevard take a look behind
me where you can see the extent of the
scene
very active scene apparently this
happened around nine
o'clock tonight we can expect to hear
more from metro
in the next 15 to 20 minutes of course
we'll keep you updated but it is a very
busy situation here
they're not letting anyone into the
apartment complex as of now
everything is blocked off you can see
the crime scene tape
and the cones as well as police just out
here kind of blocking
the area again one woman is dead that is
all we know
but we will get more updates from police
coming up later probably in the next 15
to 20 minutes
so make sure to keep it here and also
online we will have live
updates for more information on this
story reporting live madison kimbrough 8
news now